confirming they're engaged in declaring
their luck justin is first to take to
social media last night posting two
photos of the couple on Instagram with a
lengthy caption he begins writing was
gonna wait a while to say anything but
word travels fast listen
plain and simple Haley I'm so in love
with everything about you so committed
to spending my life getting to know
every single part of you loving you
patiently and kindly Justin who's
famously reaffirmed his faith and is a
member of LA's Hillsong Church also
thanks God saying quote God's timing
really is literally perfect we got
engaged on the seventh day of the
seventh month
number seven is the number of spiritual
perfection it's true google it
shortly after Justin posted Haley who
also attends Hillsong services took to
Twitter writing her own thanks to God
saying quote not sure what I did in life
to deserve such happiness but I am so
utterly grateful to God for giving me
such an incredible person to share my
life with no words could ever express my
gratitude the engagement has apparently
been in the works for quite some time
according to TMZ Justin met face to face
with Haley's dad Steven Baldwin several
weeks ago to ask him for her hand in
marriage that would place the meeting
right around the time Justin and Haley
are believed to have reignited their
romance last month